in session uh we have sanjiv Aurora from
Princeton who I think needs no
introduction but has you know both done
a lot of foundational work in theory of
computer science and learning theory and
uh more recently has been explaining uh
deep learning and is going to be talking
to us about emergence in language models
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you yeah a great Workshop
and
um
so I joined work with a fantastic
collaborator 100
if you haven't thought of so far you'll
be hearing much more
and uh I just also wanted to advertise
this new universe
started at Princeton which is Princeton
language and intelligence which is
devoted to large AI models
okay so uh
emergence
um
is this a phenomenon that when you scale
up llm from say n parameters to
Tenon parameters in tandem with data set
scaling as you saw in the previous talk
it is accompanied with significant
performance gains on many Benchmark
tasks
few short or zero shot and a related
view is that emergency is actually
ability for in context learning uh that
um the the model doesn't even need any
explicit training to do the to solve
tasks you just present the tasks to it
in natural language and it does it
so that's an alternative definition that
some people have but obviously if you're
looking at the continuous
phenomenon that's the first one that
there are performance gains and scaling
laws are uh primarily about cross
entropy loss
um
and this is the chinchilla law that with
the numbers spelled out that was alluded
to in the previous talk
uh
so here's the thing that you know I was
going around also deepmind and asking
people you know what what uh
do you find uh
weird about uh emergence and one uh
very good uh researcher who had a study
school physics background and so on so
really understands technical things said
you know I don't understand why reducing
the low order term so like this you know
as was pointed out 1.61 is something
fixed related to the language and then
the terms that are going down are these
other ones and when you
increase n by a factor of 10 n and D by
a factor of 10.
you change this terms the additional
terms by some small amount you know like
0.06 goes to 0.03
why the heck should that change to why
why does that lead to such big
differences in
macro Behavior
so we'll get to that so but here are the
plots which you also saw in the morning
session
um
uh so you know for different tasks you
see that for a while as you scale up
nothing much is going on and then
suddenly performance starts improving
okay and actually in this wear out paper
uh they also note that there's uh an
elbow in the performance for
cross-entropy loss
um
yeah at around that time
okay so we'll uh we'll try to address
that with Theory but uh I want to also
uh
point out this one phenomenon
or this one skill metal skill uh which
is ability to combine skills okay uh on
demand
so this is related to in context
learning but also the essential function
of a chatbot an interactive agent so
so for instance this was an actual uh
query I uh I would give to the language
model and say you know like this I want
a single example of two three lines of
text that illustrates these different
things you know which are captured by
NLP tasks often and uh enough for a
resolution logical inference simple
physics and judging sentiment can you
give me one please
so gpd4 says the catch is the mouse it
was very small the mouse ran into a hole
in the wall and the cat tried to follow
but got stuck looked very funny and I
couldn't stop laughing so it's
addressing all the constraints that I
set out
on demand
and now
we've seen this before in her talks and
you know the Sparks paper and whatever
you'll say it wasn't the training set
so
you can
um you can put more constraints so you
can say how about giving example in
context of hip-hop or something even
more esoteric you know medieval chivalry
or something right
plenty of physics needed for chivalry
all right so big bad so I am switching
to other models big bot says the rapper
dropped the mic and walked off the stage
he left so he's of course enough
resolution uh left a crowd roaring and
approval
uh Claude instant another uh good model
out there uh you know has something
about Lil Wayne
um and it's the bass is reverberating so
that's simple physics knowledge right
about the world oh and the size exceed
Dropbox minutes okay so
you can continue on with this okay so
you can put more constraints and see
what it does
and the point is
uh so okay actually I'll get to that in
a second I'll get to that example again
first let me just say now so with
everything I've said so far I want to
first now say what are the stumbling
blocks materials before we go on so very
little mechanistic understanding of deep
Nets deep learning is still uh not
understood very well theoretically
no clean definition of the problem what
is skill what is combination what are
tasks
um and there's plenty of work in
linguistic theory for the last many
decades and you end up with some
formalizations like context free
grammars probabilistics context
programmers Christ in logic based
theories Etc
and probably many more that I don't know
and uh they end up being formal and
rigid you know like you can't say given
natural text you know exactly what's
going on and is it being generated
According to some of these
things
then suppose you even solve that problem
right you had a formalization of what is
language
um and what are skills how do you argue
that a lot subset of them emerge roughly
in tandem as the cross-entropy laws
increases
okay and of course we don't have any
mechanistic understanding though deep
Nets
third
or fourth why do combinations of skills
also emerge that you know as it gets
better actually it's able to combine
skills flexibly
and so this was my point that I was
about to make on the previous slide
that suppose the number of skills is you
know in the thousands even
that's a very comfortable estimate you
know if you linguistic skills logical
World Knowledge all those kinds of
things
I want
and I won't need to yeah so just use
your intuitive definition
and uh
grant me that there are a thousand
skills at least
thousand to the power five
is ten to the power 15.
and remember I'm also going to ask it to
generate you know in some very
restricted domain medieval chivalry
which is only a tiny fraction of the
training set
so for sure with high probability if I
pick take a random uh many of a thousand
skills and randomly pick five
and a topic an esoteric topic this is
almost certainly not in the training set
nothing remotely like
right so that this is a simple way like
all these doubters ah it's in the
training set it's not in the training
wait wait wait wait you're assuming
you're assuming that
you know this is all you know sampled
randomly whereas you're a human writing
these things
no no no you're on the manifold of what
no no no I'm interested in take a
thousand skills you give me the Thousand
skills you'll get it could involve
coding whatever you know anything right
math
and I'll take a random subset of five of
them and ask the model they have 10 to
the 15 combinations
like in order for this to not be you
know vastly more than the number of
ranks that you would have that every
paragraph is about I don't know 10 to
the thousand ten to the fives
combinations that doesn't make any sense
so the
yeah so I'm not saying this means that
the AGI is here right that's not what
I'm saying yeah I'm just getting around
that usual objection somebody pipes up
it's in the training
okay I don't want to talk too much more
about this yeah this is not important
yeah okay
examples and so on an example doesn't
have to include only this subset and
exclude the rest and so on right that's
my money too much of the example Maybe
but any way you do the math you won't
have 10 to the 50. yeah I mean even if
there is collisions yeah I think the
point was no one's actually tried to
sample five random skills
definition of what the skill is it
doesn't matter how does it matter
we don't know what you're something from
it doesn't matter like if you have a
thousand skills and you and I agree that
these are a subset of natural skills if
I take a subset of five it it's I don't
know what the skill is even it doesn't
matter
but argument it doesn't matter if we
agree that it's a skill
if you're actually enumerate a thousand
skills yeah
so do you see this
so the question was is this the same as
you know and images of n pixels is that
two to the N possibilities that's not
what yeah
yeah okay let's not point out too much
on this you know that my point was I
think everybody agrees that
you can give GPD for
crazy things uh instructions and it does
something amazing right that we agree on
let's start with that
so
this also relates to you know this uh uh
debate about you know stochastic parrots
and Asia and so on now I don't want to
talk about AGI I mean that's a very
loaded term but you know at least the
stochastic parts to people right so and
there was this very nice uh discussion
that andrewing uh tip with uh with Jeff
Henson where Jeff was saying look the
one basic thing we have to do is in this
way is to agree on the facts
and the key fact from his perspective is
and this is
are these chatbots mirror stochastic
parrots or are they beginning to
understand us right understand us and
our work
and you know it's not clear what that
means right but certainly this kind of
thing suggests that it's able to put
itself and imagine itself in these
scenarios which are not in the trends
very many muscle
form of not being a sarcastic part
that's all I'm saying so yeah so with an
erode and uh Jonah Brown Cohen who work
with people might know is now at
deepmind uh we did some experiment by
ourselves you know so we were the
Raiders and uh at least before it
reasonably well and the other models
start to struggle you know three skills
fine you know five six
but these were very I mean I wouldn't
say they were very close
are we on the same page let's go all
right so uh clarifying the emergence
question but
um also a theory overview
so
here's a motivating example exactly
right what are skills
so the old example that everybody in AI
knows we know grad schema from 1971. the
city councilman refused to demonstrators
at permit because they feared violence
everybody knows what the sentence means
but if you start thinking about it the
day is actually ambiguous it could refer
to either
the city councilman or the demonstrators
but somehow we knew immediately that it
refers to the councilman
so well does a model understand it so
you can add What's called the close
prompt okay just multiple choice who
feared violence compliment or
demonstrators and until five years ago
models would be 50 50 between the two
they had no clue
so they hadn't figured out enough for a
resolution that's called anaphora you
know date what is it referring to
a question for you what skill or skills
I use in this example
if you're really the one talking about
no I know I mean I'm just trying to
to motivate discussion like what are
skills
I think it's just you know a whole bunch
of core occurrences
skills is a whole bunch of conferences
the reason that this works is there is a
lot of co-occurrences that that all
point to the right answer
there might not be any explicit skills
all right it's a mental construct that
doesn't actually exist in the data
yeah so okay so skill okay so for
example we agree that parsing or
understanding you know what is refused
uh
you know what are what is a permit right
what does it mean to give a permit to
demonstrate is what does that even mean
s if you
know what is not a correlation
everything is a correlation yeah so so
then but we we have to use some like
skill definition so that's this point
where you you think you think you are
doing this by correlation not by yeah
okay wow okay so you yourself think that
you have you're not ADI okay all right
okay so
all right but okay everybody as I hope
gets the point right that this logic
being used is World Knowledge there's
causality right there's because
you know because what is because right
it's causality
you don't agree all right
so by your definition then you are not
using any skills no okay good all right
so that's that's useful so I didn't know
that point of view yes that you're that
uh
uh okay all right so um
okay so uh
yes
uh oh good good
all right I forgot to say the punchline
thank you so much what skill that so
what skill was used to answer this
question and the answer is all of them
right
uh you have to understand what's because
in causality you have to understand what
are demonstrators and why they need a
permit you have to understand when
violence happens at a demonstration is
it caused by the people who gave the
permit or who got the permit out of that
right World Knowledge everything yes yes
in this case uh if we think in this way
we have a lot of sentences like this if
we ask a human to annotate
going through that listing all possible
skills containing in all sentences does
that mean that in the pre-training mode
already seen all those type of skills so
I'll get to that yeah but I think the
number of skills I think is small
maybe it's in the tens of thousands I
don't know we can discuss hundreds of
thousands but I think all skills are
there but maybe not with enough
questions good
sorry yes
you know 30 some years but I think you
know fifth grade or something we just go
through and say there's a noun there's a
yeah yeah that's boxing
wouldn't there be a token that basically
basically gave the right answer because
they could refer to either city
councilman or demonstrators it doesn't
make sense for them
wouldn't it always refer to the first
thing
okay
so there's only one agent
what agent the councilman of the ages
yeah no there are all kinds of uh yeah
how it's solved is not uh going to be a
concern here yeah
excuse me
yeah so let's go to that yeah maybe we
unless if there's a really burning
question yes
yeah
all the skills to
use
is
no point of this example except to
illustrate that the skills are mixed up
and it's not easy to separate out what
skill is used that's the only point of
this example yeah
okay so uh
all right so now let's see what does
that have to do with reduction cross
entropy right so
um just to get an Insight what's a
connection so remember this question
from my colleague you know like why does
this lower a term
you know given how large nmd are why
does that small change matter
the Insight is this there's a base
entropy this point was made earlier in
the earlier thoughts and then there's
excess right and this excess is the one
that's going down from scaling
when you scale n and D by about 10 that
access goes down
okay that's a factor two that's exactly
what my colleague was saying but
2x reduction actually is very
significant
let's see with that example
so here's the example
a model that was 50 50 right the models
five years ago a month there was 50 50
between the two examples
had
log 2 XS cross entropy
right so if you just present that you
know to the mod to the to a good model
it would say you know answer was a
and so it gets excess cross entropy log
of 1. it's deterministic
which is zero
and the model that's confused gets
excess cross entropy log of 2.
some larger constant
so this is you're working backwards from
the fact that it was 50 50. yes so you
know perfect model or human gets log one
let's call it human yes log one which is
zero and the bad model gets locked too
okay so that is the definition of excess
right so this corresponds to the base
energy right there's no entropy there
because a human is perfectly confident
and the model is getting log two so all
of that is the access term
yes
let's assume it's one from
forsake argument yeah let's say it is
actually perfect
there was a calculation you were doing
here yeah
um
I'm not sure okay
I mean I saw that working to get log one
and log two yes but how it came from the
log Earth from the it then come from
here it didn't come from here okay I'm
just saying this is all over here
this log 2
would contribute to this not to the
basic and I'm not following
why so the human has no entropy in
response to this question human is
come yes
so that's log one
so then okay so let me my next slide
says this I think I can so I can
actually answer the
because if you think about the answers
there the token that says A or B is
where these entropy is but there is a
lot of other stuff
and the answer that doesn't fall in the
category of the correct answer or not so
software all the basis so maybe let me
clarify the entropy is just you know the
choice a versus B that's what you're
saying in that you see right
any other questions
okay so right so intuitively as you as
you reduce the excess cost you know and
you can easily imagine that in real text
there was something else that was
following here where if you had this 50
50 confusion you would be predicting
wrong right this is just distilling out
that confusion we have a question
and that's called a closed question
okay so wait what happened yeah so the
point here is yeah so what is excess
cross entropy so now you might say okay
if we have to reduce excess cost entropy
let's just reduce that directly while
working with the entropy cross entropy
the answer is excess cross entropy by
definition requires a human in the
picture
so you wouldn't really need to ask
humans to read
trillions of tokens to get actual access
cross entropy and then start minimizing
it so that's not how it can happen
um just in case it's useful
you know not a diversion could you
Define excessive
exactly what it is you know so
uh
like you're at a certain place in text
you ask humans what uh the next word is
and then you get some probability
distribution on the next word so that's
the ground food distribution you ask the
model it deviates and that difference is
excess
okay
all right so it shows that excess cost
entropy you know forces the model to
reduce its confusion compared to the
human
okay
so now uh going to our work so what a
mathematical understanding is possible
for llms right now
and you know as we heard from ilia's
Hawk maybe we have three or four years
or five years left to figure this out a
little bit
um
so
all right so what we'll do is you know
it'll be a statistical framework so it
will not be too unfamiliar but we will
be able to prove generalization to
unseen combinations of skills
combinations that were not seen in the
data
scaling Rises assumed as a xiom uh and
its sidesteps the need for mechanistic
analysis of gradient updates
key assumption
and this is you know illustrated by the
example the window guard example right
there were many skills needed for that
example even to predict that you know
the answer to the question so pieces of
text involved combinations of random
capable of skills I Define a random K to
pull the end skills in a second but
that's a key assumption and then the
technical driver of the result will be
random graph Theory
which may be some fraction of the
audience would be reasonably familiar
with
and that random graph here will explain
why reduction in excess cross entropy
leads to roughly synchronized
Improvement on individual skills so it
doesn't say completely synchronized but
you can see it from the plots that it's
kind of synchronized
as well as on cave on
[Applause]
so it highlights role of skill learning
and hints at new ways to learn okay
um
so
this whole thinking about skills is sort
of implicit there you know when uh you
saw for instance uh in Sasha's talk yeah
they threw in some code data and it
improves performance on some tasks that
are in the evaluation
uh so
it's not clear exactly what even text is
anymore you know code is mixed in and
who knows what else uh synthetic data
um so our framework is kind of agnostic
about that okay it doesn't use anything
about natural language per se but about
this combinations of skills which could
happen with images and
all kinds of other modalities
okay so without further Ado let's set up
so all right so a usual language usual
modeling is not conducive to the theory
because there's nothing there to work
with except the cost entropy loss
um so what are tasks how are they
connected to one another right we're
trying to make theory about tasks what a
task how are they connected to another
where is linguistics and what knowledge
and Common Sense come in etc etc
although yeah alyosha thinks there are
no skills so I'm I'm putting some doubt
about that but okay
yes
it's a node in a graph you'll be happy
to know Okay so
so uh uh instead of you know thinking of
the Corpus is a very long sequence I'm
going to chop it up into
bits of a certain size
and
I call that the test stream so we're
looking at this is a picture for test
data okay training data doesn't make any
appearance because by scaling law we
know already what the performance is on
the test is so with reasoning about test
data
so there are pieces of text of a certain
size and text piece text the piece of
text T has a probability or measure mu 2
of T mu 2 is a value oh sorry it should
be mu 2 over there too
and then there are latent skills and the
answer to the burning question what are
skills it's a node in a graph uh so
there's just think of it as conceptually
some discrete set
which is of course you know maybe
skilled is a continuous motion but it's
a discrete set
and
uh they could involve Linguistics logic
World Knowledge common sense you know
you can
you can open up books on any of these
topics and you'll see you know types of
logical reasoning you've all seen you
know like deductive reasoning more
response Etc
so there's a long list you can get
but there are probably many others that
we don't know of because these skills
we're talking about
I I want to emphasize these are skills
from the Transformers viewpoint
so what I wrote here was you know what
we humans came up with
in trying to formalize it but really
what we're looking at is scales from the
Transformers Viewpoint which who knows
what it is okay so this is just
for illustration
and each scale also has a certain
probability mu one of s
probability according to what like
natural in in you know in this
distribution of text so we'll see I
haven't let's see let's see let's let me
just continue on the news
let's see let's see yeah I'm going to
so the mixing assumption is nature picks
a capable of skills IID from measure mu
1.
so from this set of nodes already
and then uses an unknown process
to convert it into a text PC
so that's going to be a black box in the
theory unknown process has to be who
knows what that person is
and uses some other unknown process to
assign it a probability that's also a
black box
yes
uh well but it's an unknown process yes
it's it's determined by that but we
don't know that process so so it's very
different from usual
simple statistical models where you
would say ah you take it and then you
combine it in a linear way or something
you know it's not like using the process
yeah so the probabilistic is this thing
that it's taking them
yeah but that part you can consider it
yeah it's probabilistic yeah and you
pick one sample yes
yes it it does sound like that except
topic model as I said is exactly what I
said the linear
and this is not this is some arbitrary
yes indeed
um
yeah and
how these skills figure in that we also
don't know yes
the sales
oh yes
yeah so does nature pick from the same
graph or a different so you know nature
picks kids episodes of skills and then
you know
uh this process of unknown processes
kicking
so unknown process is a part of nature
but they're unknown to us
nature knows it knows the collection of
skills yes
oh sorry nature is assumed to know what
Transformer skills are yeah
yeah
apart from what skills are is that
is it fixed dictionary of skills that is
always the same or is it possible yeah
this theory is assuming yeah okay so the
dynamic theory is very interesting but
yeah
could you just say given the Kate a
couple of skills nature samples a text
from the distribution Mewtwo
because you know you have things and
then assignment yeah yeah
yeah is there a sense in which each of
the skills can be thought of as
something like an attention like pausing
is is that you know association between
different elements it's agnostic yeah
there's no I'm not
giving any meaning purposefully
because I think it's fairly jungle
more than just Parson you know you could
also apply multiple modalities
images
[Music]
is that what you mean
you know there's some things where
you're doing a prediction and cross
entropy is a prediction loss
and we don't know where these pieces
came from you know this was
yeah
it can be randomized this one yeah yeah
isn't in a way the battle half won
because we are assuming that nature
works on top of these tasks that are
coming from this artificial
we are not resuming anything I haven't
assumed anything I don't I don't say
what these skills are whatever this is
okay couple of skills from those places
yes
the Transformer no no no I said you
can't even think of it that way uh it
may not yeah it could involve these
Linguistics logic it doesn't matter
but I'm just saying that just cautioning
that the set of skills may be much
larger
question let me move on I've uh clarify
the scenario enough let's unless if it's
yeah let's see if everything gets
answered slowly
so here's the thing so now how do we
test whether the skill has been
correctly learned or applied so the
closed sufficiency assumption is that
nature knows a set of skills and it's
going to insert a question multiple
choice question which will test your
understanding of that skill
okay similar to the Winograd example
and so
you know in this piece of text after it
generates it it inserts some questions
okay
now those questions are surprising to
the model
right it may not anticipate where nature
would put that question so it's not
required to predict the questions in the
cross entropy loss calculation
so the questions just appear and you
know model doesn't have to break them
then it sees the answers in the multiple
choice and it can read the answers and
you know the assumption is that it that
it's in a simple English so it
understands that and it just has to
predict what which answer is correct
okay and so the close sufficiency uh
assumption is that
that Nature's questions via close
prompts are squeezing out the models
uh deficiencies and understanding so the
deficiency of understanding is the
excess cross entropy what humans would
not have
and this the average cross entropy loss
was just you know squeezed out as excess
cross entropy on the on the questions
that that nature is
inserted
sorry if you can think of the prompts as
a hint
somehow
you're saying the hint is very good it's
not a hint it's a question
but it's uh saying that uh yeah so if
you think of it as hint You may actually
object to this uh assumption because you
would say that was a big hint
right but think about the Winograd
example right who
who was afraid of violence right
now maybe you could say just asking that
question makes you think harder maybe
and then so you're sort of interfering
with the process a little bit
yeah it's an assumption that basically
the models are purely lack of
understanding or confusion is squeezed
out by these questions
yes
yes that the human can answer yeah
you can easily uh
imagine that the human human has a
certain probability of answering and
then it's an excess Crossing
okay yes
might be the thing of the future yes how
would that
going to you you would have to extend
the theory yeah this is
more static Theory yeah
okay can this assumption be empirically
tested on a bunch of closed problems
Benchmark times uh that's a good
question but yeah I haven't
and it hasn't already in itself
all right
I would argue that it has been in the
sense that
um yeah yeah some that would be my
impact yeah
depends again depending on how you
wanted to find a task you could say that
a given like you know natural language
inference is a task and analy data sets
test that task so exactly yeah thank you
yeah so Holland is probably one of the
experts things designing these
evaluations and so on so yeah at least
I'm glad to hear that you have these
Okay so
all right so now measuring Proficiency
in skills and purpose of skills
so we have this bipotype graph where you
know every skill
you know Kate episode skills produce
pieces of things so therefore each
individual uh skill is involved in some
pieces of text
so
um
all right so that right so each skill s
is involved in the subset of the text
pieces so that's a sub Distribution on
text pieces
right so if I look at it from the point
of view of any individual skills look at
all the pieces it got used in
and that's the sub distribution
so the close uh sort of observation is
that if the close prediction was
successful on t
then uh all K skills were corrective
right I'm not sure if I should call it
observational that's an assumption you
know that if because we're saying that a
close prediction was successful then you
applied the skills that's the definition
okay
now what happens when it when when the
close prediction was incorrect
okay so now you failed to predict that
it was uh the councilman that were
afraid of violence
what which of the skills did you fail at
did you not understand what's because
you didn't understand what are
demonstrations any of those right so
they're all these skills that were used
we'll assume that they were all
incorrectly applied
yes
if you apply two skills kind of
incorrectly so that's what I'm answering
that
um if the answer is incorrect to the
close question I'm assuming that all
skills will encouraged by so that's a
kind of conservative bound as you'll see
uh so I'm asking is if you successfully
do
you could have incorrectly applied two
skills that like cancel out right right
this is ignoring that it's assuming that
at least on average if you're
doing it correctly then uh you are
applying this good practice yeah
sorry none of the other uh n minus case
skills
they also assumed no correctly applied
here on this team that's what I'm saying
but the team might they might have apply
other skills as well more 2K skills on
the whole no so that's what we're
assuming that the Nature has basically
given you a catalog of case skills
maybe where you're going with is you
know different pieces of text may have
different number okay and that just
makes as you can imagine the random
graph Theory
hopeless so I'm keeping it at one click
okay so now the failure rate of the
model on scale s is just a loss on close
prediction
from this distribution
okay so that's your that's answer to
your uh question uh this is you know
you're basically reducing it to some
kind of financial
uh that skill and uh similar definition
with thoughts corresponding okay Prime
couples of skills okay Prime less than k
uh like pairs of skills you know you
take pairs of skills and see which
pieces of text they are part of and then
go from there
the model the the analysis doesn't need
to know yeah
so it's not composition it's combination
you know those two skills appear in that
and if you don't
uh if the model doesn't solve the closed
question correctly then you assume that
basically all the skills that we use
were incorrectly applied there
it's a very conservative estimate so
your lower bounding how good your your
proficiency is on the skills you may be
more proficient despite making errors
but if you're making errors it's
assuming you're just not sufficient
okay so again same thing so just to
illustrate suppose nature produced this
piece of text using a five couple of
scales
then this piece of text appears in the
distribution for five statistical
thoughts for each of those five skills
five choose two statistical tasks
corresponding to pairs of skills if I
choose three physical thousand percent
triples of skills Etc okay
so it's like a whole universe of tasks
let's choose K tasks statistical tasks
okay and then yeah as Colin said all
these stars that maybe are used in NLP
are using some subset of scripts
okay so uh why emergence
and uh so what I I forgot to say on the
previous slide that uh you know the what
the picture of the skills and so on is
called a skill cluster and uh
you could imagine Corpus having multiple
skill clusters and I'll address that
later but for now we discuss a corpus
where there's a single set of skills and
then this piece of text the process I
described was one cluster
so how does the model get better
well we know remember we are assuming
that the cross entropy on the on the
answers to the closed questions is
tracking the overall cross entropy so as
a scaling loss kick in and the model
gets better at Cross entropy you will
also see that it's answering the closed
questions much better
we're just testing the models
understanding
so
so these are the errors uh on closed
questions the big X
and as you scale up the models cross
entropy improves and the assumption is
that these errors will also go down
so for instance like this okay so
okay so as you scale up the closed
questions are getting answered more and
more
all right and so
how does this affect error rate on
password for skills and skill topics
foreign
tell you the incorrect way to think
about it which is that is this a random
graph so all skills are equally affected
you know you take any
set of places where the errors are
happening and basically every skill will
have about the right number of
proportion of edges there and so on
that's not exactly true
okay so it's the reason it's not true
is that these errors depend on the
training process and
details of uh the training set and so on
and so
and then there are these unknown
processes that link these different text
pieces
so
after training you cannot assume that
you know these edges
with respect to where the errors are are
random you cannot
if only uniformly random yeah
even if they were put in randomly
conditional on knowing where the errors
are
you cannot think of them as a random set
of edges but you're still using
statistical
yeah yeah
correct it's just not very important
yeah that's a random graph here
okay any questions
with all this build up now I'm ready to
give you the theorems okay
so
um so why emergence
oh oh I managed to go back I see I got
confused
it wasn't making sense
sorry
okay good oh this was so good
okay good yeah
so what we want is the emergence curve
right the Cisco process that Proficiency
in task increases it's a continuous
thing and some of the previous talks
mentioned that you know the illusion
that it suddenly emerges is uh just that
an illusion and you can do it properly
you should see just continuous
Improvement as you improve the model or
scale of the model and the curve I'm
talking about is you know set of X Y
pairs so in a plane right uh in a graph
such that when the excess cross
entropies data then for at least X
percent of skills the model has
classification laws and most gamma on
the physical task associated with that
skill
foreign
skills on proficiency on skills to this
prediction task and
that's the set of X Y pairs you know
what Frac for what fraction of
skills the classification loss is less
than one so what is the dependence on
care
uh so K is uh going to be in there
because you know you'll see the
expression
it depends on okay
okay so this is the first theorem this
is for uniform distribution uniform U1
and mutuals the two men
and that's really classical random graph
Theory and by the way this figure was
done by
gpd4 uh in the last minute rush um
so
um so that's a conceptual picture right
these are
skills these are the text pieces and
this graph connecting them is random uh
even though they're these arbitrary
measures and so on
but that measures are now uniform
so the
um
the curve that I was talking about is uh
uh anyway the curve that I mentioned is
given by this expression so it depends
on Theta and K and then Alpha Beta are
like the X and Y roughly but it's in
this expression it's like if excess
cross entropy losses Theta then there
are one minus Alpha times N2 skills such
that model as error less than beta times
Theta online so parametrization is it
involves Spader here
okay
and
entropy is the usual entropy
so just to give you an idea so suppose
Theta is 0.1 the x is crossing 3.1 and
Alpha is point two beta is three then
for at least 0.8 fraction of skills the
model asks answers incorrectly in point
three fashion effect
and as I emphasized earlier this is the
minimum guaranteed performance because I
have a very conservative estimate of
performance
so uh in practice you know the random
graph Theory maybe pessimistic and
honestly
okay
so uh
uh yeah so and and you can see the the
random graph theory is coming in because
this for all one we don't know you know
what this set is where the errors are so
we have to reason about all why so
anyway so this is for uh
this is just done by uh probabilistic
method to show that it holds a high
probability for all one the fraction of
y's that violated is
or the expected fraction
um the thing that's been puzzling me the
whole talk is like random graph Theory
can tell us about like sudden emergence
of you know connectedness
graph but here it seems like we only
care about eight doubles
right that like like we so right now I'm
only talking about
nodes I'm just talking about skills I
haven't given I haven't talked about the
top of in this theorem I'm coming to
that so this is just individual skills
which are notes
right
talk about
it it happened suddenly that like all
these skills you know so and so for that
out to give you the picture so you know
so this is what it is you know you're
not you can't wrestle with this anymore
this is what it is and so we have to
plot it to see
yeah
uh all right oh and so and then the
weighted version you know with arbitrary
measures is just a more complicated
version
of the probabilistic method
which required some work
so these are the curves okay so that's
your that's answer to your question so
you know you're not going to get some
single expression that describes
emergence it's this collection of Curves
and you can reason about the course
based on the math amount of time
yeah so this is 4K uh different K and
Theta Theta is point one so it's a
different k for same Theta and there's a
simple quality of the theorem that
increasing K shifts the curve below and
to the right that is this bettering
margins yes
Etc that that emergence should apply to
so what's that global point of view
yeah so okay so this is just competency
skills
yeah so emergence I'm talking about is
that your performance on a bunch of
thoughts improves and for me tasks are
either you know the statistical classes
so the individual skills or the top of
the skills and I'm showing the result
for those okay because if there's no
Global phenomena and then it seems like
we should just be able to write an
explore president like you know
whatever to the K power right and it
should be smooth right like the
probability that all these skills is
equal to you know the probability that I
have one skill raised to the power I
didn't understand that it probably
there's a mission
okay so the the simple color is that K
increasing K shifts the importance uh
shifts the curve below to the right and
that's better in markets right so uh you
are you have more skills that have good
uh that similar or better uh performance
and what is higher K I think of that as
a substitute for data quality or proxy
for data quality that more complicated
data right these days apparently the
human readers have to be like have
college degrees so you know they can
write skills they can use more skills
than a piece of text so high kids that
are politics
then the emergence course of K Prime
couples of skills this is I just say in
one line it's a tensorization argument
characterization argument and that's
what gives you that but the bottom line
is that basically if uh you know the
size of theta reduces that factor of two
then whatever performance you're getting
for single skills you get prepared you
reduce it by another factor of two then
whatever performs you're getting for
players
so as the models are scaled up you'll
see a better Improvement on
um yes did you get like all pairs no no
no similar it's this curve you know some
fraction on some fraction of tuples
you'll see a certain point s but the
overall curve of that is exactly the
shifting up so
here is the tune of skills the two pairs
of skills that you get correct rise
continuously as status false
um
okay that is not the claim uh because uh
you know this is this transformation
argument is not exact you know again all
of these are all underestimating
always all consistent but that I don't
know how to prove that
yes this is a fast summary
it's a lot hidden yeah
that the emergence of these complex
abilities arises as a phase transition
due to the normally
yeah so maybe let me finish and then
take more questions if you have time uh
yeah so that's it yeah so and again so
yeah you see that you know if you if you
increase uh
the scaling by you know towards the
magnitude then what was the curve for
single skills becomes
it's don't worry about it it's just you
know the fractional skills yeah yeah so
um
so the point is uh you know you've only
had a cuts and Factor increase in in
amount of data and you were suddenly
seeing good performance and quadruptions
so it definitely didn't have a
polynomial increase in the moment
that's mathematically important
that's the key takeaway here
can you can you repeat that so you know
these curves so what I'm saying is when
you increase the amount of data by a
factor of 10. the curve for one triple
shifts from here to here and this
becomes the curve for the pairs of
skills you have another order of scaling
10 Factor 10 and you know quadruple is
doing as well as single skills so your
performance on K-POP rules called tuples
is increasing much more than polynomial
much better than you know the amount of
data
it's some kind of a
yeah
it's another way to think about it let
me let's restrict questions to exactly
if you don't understand something other
than what
okay and so yeah this I want to say but
yeah there's an explanation you know
like these skating laws implicitly uh
suggesting phenomena like
that you know as you scale up you need
less data for the same amount of
learning and that's what's going on
okay much less than the naive counting
the political thing uh this was an
illustrative experiment that you know
you can learn to recognize multiples of
digits which is 10 to the four
combinations from actually 10 to the
three or labeled examples
and extensions of the theory they are
non-inform distributions already
mentioned General skill clusters you
know you could have different scale
clusters like basic English Math logic
whatever you know or science
uh and you could have different skill
clusters and then you know there isn't a
clean Theory because we don't know if
progress happens similarly on all those
clusters and at what rate then so all of
that is not uh you know it can only be
settled by experiments
okay
yeah emergence in different clashes may
happen at different scales
not likely that's about uh and the last
thing I want to emphasize again
returning to this magical ability of
chatbots to like combine skills on
demand I call uh oh another thing I call
it procedural thinking for one of the
better word I mean in all of these we
are trying to use 20th century
Notions to explain 21st century
phenomena and uh the procedural thinking
is roughly that you know you're given
describe the task and then you know
you're identifying some arguments and
some procedure that has to be applied
using those arguments
and uh so that's what we call procedural
thinking and that's
somehow emerging and of course it's just
a couple of skills you know these all
individual skills you can come to my
skills so they will emerge from scaling
but maybe they can emerge better than
that as well so concluding thoughts
Elementary and plausible accounts
explains phenomena such as learning
skills about singular training data uh
highlights importance of procedural
thinking
and some particular thing appears in our
Theory you just presumably by statistics
but but probably there's more going on
in Berkeley and our closed are
sufficient to test most interesting
skills and cognitive scientists seem to
think it's pretty jungle it's not
promotional skills seems emitting you
know uh proficiency on skills on this
distribution
and the whole point of a language model
or AI models is that they seem to work
outside of the train distribution so
uh that's implementing so that's just
the first activity so I'll stop there
thank you very much
[Applause]
take one question
and then others can ask uh send you
about lunch
so it's another way to think about this
is that for each of these skills as you
train more the skill skill a little bit
better so it's instead of having a skill
or not just you have different
continuous Improvement yes and that is
it requires five skills to do a task
in in each skill gets better by a factor
of two it's 32 times better to do the
task and then it suddenly emerges that
you can do the task there's a non-linear
like that I mean not exactly that math
but yeah but that's kind of a
qualitative way yeah okay thank you yeah
um
okay apparently I can do more questions
according to you much
lead powder here well okay so I was
trying to kind of reconcile my worldview
with yours and here is one attempt okay
what if you have
a huge amount of skills if you have
skills on the order of the amount of
training data okay then this Theory
doesn't apply I see like this this
doesn't talk so you assume that your
skills is a is a very sparse
you know it could be ten thousand a
hundred thousand but it's not
Terror right all right we are still in
this agreement
so uh in this example based off is that
other question of this continuous
Implement like Epsilon to the fifth
power it at the end of the day did you
have like a non-linear the the were you
looking at accuracy or error some
non-linear metric that you put at the
end of your uh
measuring oh I see so I was assuming yes
probabilities and so yeah the
calculation I was showing was assuming
that you know uh if you are in that set
of data where you know by averaging this
like error at least half or something on
the gross question then you completely
failed
I was not taking that thing yeah it just
give me a completely yeah so since
you're Discerning if you if you feel
comfortable with the
end that we are achieving the initial
empirical drawstring short almost had a
phase transition almost zero yeah but
it's on a log scale yeah
so remember remember that that we think
that uh performance goes with excess
cross entropy right not cross entry they
are they are doing cross-entrification
right so when excess goes down by a
factor two it means almost not show on
the graph but yeah it's massive for
classification
uh so I do NLP so I don't really
understand math but my question would be
um so like what is the most surprising
empirical phenomena that you think your
theory can predict that we cannot
predict if we haven't listened to the
talk
uh that you can give gpd4 at least and
maybe the other models too like a large
take any set of skills reasonably set
and take five couples and can compose
now that's not AGI but I'm just pointing
out that that's not enough data in the
training set maybe that's one key
takeaway I mean even if the material
doesn't impress you like that's fine but
that is very common yes
[Music]
yes
you started rephrasing you started with
the sentence you're saying okay a few
years ago
now you can get it right so there was
something yeah get it wrong in the way
you know the policemen the demonstrators
whatever
all the languages yeah and uh and your
theory was saying okay all of a sudden
with this emergence of skills graph
Theory can maybe explain to us why they
emerge but another way to ask it about
being actionable can you say how much
data you need could you pull out how
much data you need out of your formula
part of your analysis to say when some
other set of scales would emerge right
so the the problem here is that you know
what uh ayurchester happy with what is a
set of skills
so this is a qualitative theory in that
sense right like do you have a complete
cataloging of skills
yeah
so right so it's a qualitative Theory
completely I completely
sanjiva guy obviously had at most K
minus one of the skills needed to
understand this talk
okay my question this way like why why
is it not obvious like as I improve each
of my individual skills I will also
improve on you know any subset of K of
the skills at some rate that I can
calculate like why do I need graph
Theory to tell me that
so the the driver is not that you're
improving the skills drivers you're
reducing cost center okay so it's not
even trivial to argue that if you so
like you have now one percent of the
training set where there is errors
what is a fraction of edges from
Individual nodes on the other side that
are going to that set
it's an arbitrary set
um okay I think we should break very
large okay all right okay
[Applause]
so we'll come back here at 2PM